the thing about christas vacation is
that it's taken kind of Precedence it's
like a a high point in that whole
franchise so Juliet and Johnny did you
guys were I mean you were the third set
of griswell children were you aware of
that when you we were totally aware of
that we played natural siblings this guy
over here how old were you then halfway
through filming I turned 14 really he
was a year younger than me but of course
I thought I was 25 Julia was the coolest
15-year-old that over walked the planet
Dian how did you end up in this movie I
went down to Salvation Army and got an
old pair of glasses and some oxfords we
put my hair up in a shinan and I put
talcum powder and I put it all over my
head and now I go in and I played with
your jaws and opened your mouth and went
inside and played games on your face and
said I love you sunny boy and I got the
job